guys sorry I'm wearing my sunglasses I
haven't got his lids on operation no you
oh my gosh you haven't see my eyes oh oh
yeah now did you get beat with two bats
or one I got beat with two bats but
apparently the swelling will go down and
that's what happened then it looks
better apparently this is this is this
is permanent who's like you got stung by
more bees than I that's right this is
permanent and this is what I'm gonna
look like so thank you very much
everybody
without him on but it might be too
distracting so we might want to keep
this on that's not distracting alright
right there's a hurt low desert that
doesn't hurt there's no pain it doesn't
hurt and that weird your eyes no your
eyes just don't have a lot of maybe
nerve endings in it oh now your lids are
the worst
I thought your lids would be the it's
funny cuz the doctor your lids are the
worst and I can show my concern that's
right
you look you know you look awful yeah
yeah well the doctor goes oh great
perfect
great job it'll go down a little bit
we'll take the stitches out on Monday I
was like no I wouldn't have done this
where the stitches that up top yeah
they're up top there along the lid it's
so crazy and then I was I was picking
his brain on how faceless work and all
that they take your face off
oh do they oh they take your face at the
movie they can do like they they're you
have velcro essentially it's like this
weird fashion thing where they could sew
don't kid yourself anybody's ever got in
the face that has had their face
basically taken off and just though this
is a short operation this is the
simplest shortest operation which is
which takes two hours a lot of times
he's standing there sitting for 10 hours
surgeons like that or he lives - yeah
maybe you're under to a showers yeah I
googled the eye Google's the whole
procedure did you feel terrible when you
woke up you know what he's just so
unhealthy I I guess it is cuz I woke up
and I didn't know where I was I put my
pants on I was talking apparently
apparently they wheeled me out and I was
like this I was like anesthesia also bad
for you it is right dude yeah
whether we're seeing do to your body
they say I'm sure I'm sure you're it's a
nerve blocker it's everything and then
the antibiotics don't make you feel good
so I was like hey let's take these and
he was like yeah does it hurt that bad
but when you believe doesn't hurt it's
just it's just I
feel like I'm I feel like I just pushed
my face into a giant tack they're like
balloon like a water balloon like I feel
like I'm putting on my face is on a warm
you like you're underwater yeah yeah and
how long til they go back to normal
because we're in the fight fan on
Saturday thing could be normal by then
oh yeah hey you're you have a little
thing any knows what there it is what's
the buzz or something I was like peace
on it it's bothering me thanks dude yeah
so uh so there's that there's that pop
we got his lids done yeah I will never
get any plastic surgery so just again no
it's so nasty it is that I mean I hope
that I don't you know hopefully you're
not all [ __ ] up but think about like
the Kardashians all the procedures
they've got is so unhealthy when you
look at what she's been through like
that one girl complete completely
different tightly complete guy Lee
Reformation just complete I mean here
they're breaking bones the [ __ ] chair
jaw line they put implant breaking they
extend their hips their remaining ribs
are they root yeah yeah yeah smaller
that's how they get the that's not true
yeah that's all YouTube you can remove
read about that many times you see if
that's really get the V and then they
blow out their ass I don't believe that
I promise people do it all the time
removal surgery removing one or more
ribs that's [ __ ] you know if celebrities
have been full of gate let me see who's
that blonde the guy or the girl indirect
I think the girl looks like a who's that
girl that's so weird
and then they were those were they don't
girdles or something of course their
corsets well people have been doing that
for centuries that women used to faint
when they do it pixee her name's pixie
well she removed it to get a 14 inch
waist
that would make yeah let's not worry
about pixie right now he's right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]